all right I think we can get started
quick show of hands how many of you are
web developers over here right web
applications okay it's a fair few how
many of you still continue to write
desktop applications all right maybe
that's it's a twenty eighty split I
guess
anyway one of the things about both
kinds of application is that they're
they use completely different
technologies when you're writing them if
you look at web application HTML
Javascript CSS and one nice thing about
writing web applications is you can
actually write at once
and no matter what operating system that
you're running it whether it is on when
you're running on Linux Mac or Windows
you can still run it without any
problems and pretty much more or less
irrespective of what kind of browser you
use whether it's a Chrome or Safari or
edge or IE you know it more or less
works right
desktop applications on the other hand
completely different technology when
you're writing it how many of you still
running web using WinForms well few
hands right yeah yeah don't be a scary
guy we are not going to judge you right
what about WPF yeah yeah more like it
who actually did silver lining what
mommy or your yeah
so the like you know I almost became a
satellite MVP so it respect of what you
do I mean like if you look at a web
application even if you're using C sharp
or asp.net or even vb.net and even Java
on the server effectively it splits out
HTML right on the other hand when you're
writing a desktop application completely
different technology and you know we
even have legacy applications that are
in our company that that we use that use
Delfy anybody done Delfy
yeah yeah
written with the first page the first
better version of Delfy for Windows 3.1
yeah the biggest problem with all the
desktop applications is that well they
run on Windows fairly well even the
Delfy application runs even now it runs
quite well but when you want to start
moving it across to a Mac or Linux when
you want to make it cross-platform you
have a big problem and the web
applications right I mean you can run it
on a browser and it's pretty good but
then the problem with the browser is it
runs in a sandbox environment and you
want to say well you know what I want to
go pick some files from the file system
and display it on this gun on the
browser you can't do it it's off limits
right if you want to connect to a
database you can't do it I mean you can
do it through some code running on the
server and things like the bridges can't
do it right it's all sandbox environment
that's the way it's meant to be now but
wouldn't it be cool like where would be
awesome right if you could actually use
the same web technology HTML Javascript
you guys were in Scott Hanselman ski
note yesterday right you know how he was
actually talking about JavaScript being
the assembly language of the web and
things like that and how you know how
everybody should be using it would it be
cool if you could use all the same
technologies that we are really familiar
with HTML Javascript CSS and write
applications desktop applications use
the you know the leverage the power of
the desktop but write it with HTML
that's what this talk is all about it's
all about a technology called electron
my name is Mahesh Christian I work as
CTO at Telstra health got a grand title
of CTO where you know I'm a developer at
heart and my co-presenters christian
pereira is the technical architect ari
is the technology on Mahesh no he's
technically well you know one thing I
would Christian is when I offered him
the job I said oh you come and join me
and John is an architect and he said you
know what I Swan one change I said what
is it you know do you want more more
salary it's something more books and
then can you please change the title
from architect or something else
so what is it to see it are there any
architects by the way it's right any
Architects around here yes yeah without
any offence or things like that but I
work for a big company a big corporation
and in that big corporation architects
had the title of throwing boxes and tell
somebody else to do and I love code so I
say like you know what I want to write
code this is what I do so can you just
shut in the title we don't wear any
offense right I don't want to offend
architects here but but that's that's
the difference I write code architects
where I work don't I love to you know
tip alright if you really want to annoy
Christine don't call them an architect
call them an enterprise sake
yeah anyway coming back to our topic
so what is what is electron so by the
way you know do you get this thing which
it's an atom and it's got an electron
and everything else I thought it's
pretty cool right and Christian thing
that's bringing I don't I get and of
course I must boss so so so what is
electron you go look at the Technion you
go look at the website on and you got
this this definition the framework for
building cross-platform bla bla bla bla
bla but what does it really mean right
three things one is you can use electron
to write desktop applications using web
technologies the stuff that I actually
said earlier HTML Javascript CSS and you
can use any JavaScript framework whether
it is angular how many people use
angular over here yeah one or two right
one two okay whatever you want right
angular one angular 2 you can use react
you can even use you know the library
that Scott Hanselman was showing
yesterday cuz it was a fast scrolled is
probably s best library yeah you can you
can use it put it in a demo and get your
boss to demoed and a really important
meeting I'll go down well anyway it
really doesn't matter right you can use
any JavaScript library that you want to
use and the nice thing about and the
reason that everything actually works in
desktop application is that they run
everything in chromium so chromium for
all those they don't know it's
effectively the opens was version of the
Chrome browser that Google has provided
it comes with the v8 JavaScript engine
and it can run all the JavaScript and
node.js as well in it okay one nice
thing about actually running it on on a
Chrome browser or chromium browser is
that unlike a web application right you
got to test it on different browser
types like you know Firefox and edge and
ie and things like that you don't have
to worry about anything you know exact
you you don't have to worry about
whether chrome is installed on the you
know on the user's machine or anything
it all it's all packaged together and
they can actually use it yeah and that
is important we actually have to deliver
an application that to make sure that it
will look correctly as part of the
installer we have to install Chrome so
just imagine that that that's that's how
things can became critical yeah so so
this is this is a really nice thing that
but when you're running a in a browser
it's all sandbox right if you want it
like I said earlier if you wanted to use
any of the you know access the file
system any system level functionality
and things like that you just cannot use
it but with electron you can actually do
it the second thing is that this is an
open source project from github
now how many you have any of you used
looked at atom editor right so Adams the
text editor from from from github and
they started on this project about three
years ago and I think in the first arted
looking at other things like you know
node WebKit and a few other options that
they looked at and they found none of
that really suitable for what they want
to do which they fect build a text
editor in hich tml in javascript so what
do they do they roll out their own right
and so in 2014
you know they open sources it was called
the atom shell back then and then in
2015 it effectively became electron yeah
if you are a little more interesting
about this random poster from github is
giving a tour about how they made
electron yarn is tomorrow 11:40 yeah but
it's gonna be talking about the
internals of how editing works
everything else as well so highly
recommend going to that dog
but it's one of what the reason I
actually mentioned this is that it's not
like a small site project that's being
done by a couple of people I mean it's
it's got a lot of backing particularly
from github there are a lot of big
companies that are using it including
people like Microsoft the third thing I
want to do is like we talked about
cross-platform it works on Windows Mac
and Linux and you can package your
application and then you can you know
you can run it on on these plans on
these three platforms and you get the
native look and feel on the platform
that you're running it and that's the
key thing it's not like a you know you
run it on a web browser and everything
just works on you know it doesn't look
like a native application right it does
because it uses all the native
components in it I know some people are
probably thinking at this time like how
is this different you actually said that
it's actually like a shell that's
running uh like a you know browser
window on it or browser shell and it's
running HTML on it how is it different -
let's say running of WinForms
application bf application warrior yeah
that one as well
yeah or actually having a browser
control on it yeah right I mean the same
thing works right you can pass it URL to
DES and this works I mean you know I've
got a desktop application I'm writing
using HTML on it
so why is it Christian okay that's
actually a good question and I have had
a story related to that we work what I
just got into the job I have to go and
see all the other projects and one of
those price I remember was a winform
application and when I go there they
just display a map and displays a lot of
data in a table and things like that and
I remember asking to the developer hey
this controls look really nice which
control said I use and because it's
waveform so like oh no we couldn't find
anything that adjust to what we wanted
so what we do is that we generate HTML
on the fly and then display that in a
web browser right and a web browser
control so again like just to complement
that is it happens and people does that
yeah the difference is you can just do
cross-platform let's use summary summary
in forms and put a web control over
there they are like two big different
with that the first one is that in all
those applications you are tied to the
web control of the operating system so
in the case of Windows you will use
Internet Explorer render right not even
edge Internet Explorer render for
Windows and if you are using something
like for example Mac you will use UI web
bill so that's the first difference and
the second big difference is that you
are basically having an application
inside another application because it's
inside of web browser is in a shell
it's sandbox you can no escape from that
web page yeah so even you can lie to
yourself and say things like oh I can't
I can't open a file because I will use
the file browser stuff but know that
that's that's not a thing you cannot get
out from that yeah so you cannot even
communicate from that web you to the
application that is your container yeah
effectively you think about it as to two
separate applications one is the
applications that is hosting the shell
and that's independent and you do stuff
with it and then you have the browser
control and that is independent and they
don't talk to each other and that's not
what we want to have yeah I want to have
a seamless application it's all in HTML
and you can also go out and access
things from the file menu or you know
you do things from the file menu and
things happen on the web browser yeah so
how does the structure of an electron
application look like so let's go in and
quickly look at a very simple hello
world application on electron it
consists of three components three files
if I can call it that right if you are
familiar with node node you've probably
recognize packages or JSON so what the
package dot JSON file does contains
effectively nothing more than the name
of the application and and the entry
point for the JavaScript file where you
actually write the application needs to
start and if I go look at the JavaScript
file itself it's also pretty simple and
it's got two things two main things in
it that I want to point out one is that
when the application is ready you're
basically telling it when that event
happens go ahead and and create a window
what the create window function does is
it actually goes ahead and does this it
creates a new browser window you know he
said with
and height and everything yeah we will
talk a little more about this yeah in
the nestled ISO and then all you do is
you load a URL and that URL is affecting
the index of HTML file that I've got as
a third file in this case the index of
HTML is a extremely simple one right so
hello world
HTML does really nothing much and that's
it right so once you create these three
files that's enough to get you started
with an electron application now if
you're writing a complex application
obviously you have a lot more files
you'll arrange it in a nice much better
for the structure you will have your
JavaScript libraries you'll have your
CSS files and you have a lot more HTML
files and things like that but this is a
very trivial example with just three
files that can this can actually get you
get you started now you know there are
two processes that electron application
will run one is the main person the
render process you want to talk a little
bit more about that Chris yeah sure
again as I said it's not just a web
browser embedded in a main application
that is not the secret here is that you
can not from web technologies access
things regarding to the desktop and
things like that that's a fact so what
they did but you can do that from
node.js for example so what you have is
what they call the main process in the
main process is the thing that access
with everything else the menus the file
system everything else it's like node.js
embedding fact it's basing the node es
source code is and v8 engine but it's
not know GS as I said you have like
access to the IPC no GS NPM modules or
all the modules from NPM you can use
them right so all those thousands of
modules from no GS you can use in your
in your electron applications dialogues
our menus are from there and then what
happens is that every time that you want
to display something in a window you
create another process that is called
the render process and that render
process contains your HTML file right
and now this is the stuff how they
communicate they didn't create a new
protocol or anything like that
rating system since the beginning they
just have this deal to deal with to
communicate between to process so they
use IPC and IPC modulus or package or
support are in both size so every time
that for example you know you want to
know that somebody clicks in the file
open or file something in an action if
that has to affect in any case the
render process you just like do an IPC
message using no GS IPC mechanism and
the other received that and you can
change the UI that is very useful as
well because you can have some many
render process that you have it's very
common in a win in Windows desktop
application Magister especially mat
destur application that you have the
document metaphor and you have many
documents open at the same time in
different windows so that's the big
difference the main processes is the
equivalent to the things that are
running and you cannot see and can spawn
as many browser process of you want you
can look at it in a slightly different
way as well you can think of a chrome
that actually runs it as the main
process yeah so you see here that you
have the title the file the menu things
like that that are interacting directly
with that for example notifications and
things like that as part of the main
process and then you have the renderer
with the conscious and the thing that
you display that's in the render of
window process the browser window so so
what are you do to run this application
itself pretty simple I mean of course
you need all the the electron bits to
run it so if you've got node already
installed you basically go and say npm
install and you pass electron pre-built
into it and that's it right that
installs all that component obviously we
want to do we won't do it here
you know the hotel bandwidth and
everything else it's like using angular
2 it will download the whole engine one
important thing here and I will go
escape is that electric you can build
your own version of electron you can
download the source code and build it
you will just need the GIP that is the
no GS binary system for compilation but
I would recommend electron pre-built it
will just download the binary support
there
rating system that you are running in
that moment so you're around easing
windows it will run the banners for
Windows format the same thing and so on
once you do that you know electron
followed by the name of the folder where
you got all your files and that's it
very simple and you'll have it often
right electronics just going to run your
package to JSON file that is in that
folder will find the main entry I will
try to run that at the main entry see
that the main GS file the of the main
entry is the equivalent to your main
code in C sharp or something like that
all right so it's demo time and so what
what I want to do is we want to show you
a bunch of applications starting with
will show a bunch of applications that
we that we've that are available that
have been already written an electron
but quickly I'll show you that hello
will app and it's not much of an
application but
what I want to show you is I mean uh you
know there's nothing much to it it looks
like a any other desktop application you
know it's got a file menu and everything
else
it's not much however if I hit ctrl
shift I because it's running on the
chromium browser I actually get all the
dev tools that are there in the Chrome
browser right you can disable this if
you want but that actually shows up and
the resolution is pretty crappy but you
know but if I actually look at you know
I can do inspect objects and a whole
bunch of things that you wouldn't
normally do if you have JavaScript code
you can actually look at it you can see
what components have been downloaded and
all those things that you would normally
do when you're debugging an application
in chrome itself so you get all those
features built in just to give you a
quick summary of applications that are
available that are being written on on
electron let's see yeah how many of you
have actually used Visual Studio code
anyone did you guys know there was
written in electron yeah what about
slack slack certain on an electron as
well so need these are some of the apps
that are written people actually use it
all the time but they don't realize that
it's actually being written an electron
now with slack for example I thought I
disabled all those things all right I
have many birthdays today man yeah
apparently straw hunts a birthday today
as well do you guys know ya know this is
a slack right so notice that it had
integration on the system tray and it's
not run slack now this just seemed like
just blame the Wi-Fi that's the Internet
it's really awesome so anyway so notice
that it actually had this integration of
the system tray all this is actually
possible because of the the close
integration that it has with the the
native operating system itself so on on
a on a Mac this will look different on
Windows obviously pops up over here and
so on it's probably a good idea to
and do a quick demo of yeah another few
applications that I love as well that
has been ridden with electron let's try
this to see if it works
who knows can you connect this it's on
that side I'm sorry man I'm totally new
to Mac that just to you okay
the first thing is that the guys from
electron itself they have a long list of
applications that are being written with
electronic some of them you actually get
surprised that they were breeding with
electron as you can see one of thing is
Visual Studio code things that you this
is Visual Studio code with a C++ project
or a sip ploy it does not C++ guy I
prefer playing C notice the menu
integration and one of the favorite
things that I see in Visual Studio code
oh and you can just open directories
inspect the content of the directory
suspect the type of files things that
you cannot do in a web application
because all of those things what happens
is they are happening in the main
process and they are just telling to the
render process this is the list right so
that is important tip if you try to do
things that's complex at this you have
to create your own protocol or the way
the lightweight protocol between there's
those two things to talk I'm
communicating I know I think that we can
see here that I actually like it a lot
is that thanks to that that you are
drawing something locally you have the
power to leverage extensions you can
create extension points in your
JavaScript application so you allow all
the users to extend your application
using plugins that was one of the first
thing that we start looking when we
start designing the new application so
the new breed of applications that we
have to work with we working in the
medical industry and it's very common
there that you have to - you can not
think I had all of the things that
hospital so people are going to do with
your software so it would be easier
than to say like you know what we have
extension points and you can just create
your own UI for that specific thing and
things like that and the only thing that
you have to do is just create a package
and things like that and it's JavaScript
and it will work and that is one of the
things that I love from from running
electron applications you can you see in
the examples and most of them support
plugins and it's pretty simple another
application that I like a lot is the one
who started everything obviously Auto me
Optimus is awesome I like it
it's basically kind of an idea is not
just an editor anymore one of the things
that you can see here as well it is
support for teams how does this work and
it's very common the same as plugins I
want my application to look different
think about the support for your local
desktop application to support branding
that you want to bring branding to
different customers depending on the
store in the case again of medical
industry depending on the hospital we
want that the application to look very
different so the reason because this is
easy to do an electron is that the
branding or the team support is just CSS
it's just plain web technology you can
just make it look as different as you
want there are just HTML elements that
will make things change so that is the
secret atom with the things and you just
like to make it look completely
different
I hate that on the light thing so let's
return to the dark another application
that we have here is wigle wigle is a
data science application it's basically
a sequel browser one of the things that
it does is that you can connect to
database no note and it has a huge
variety of support for databases in the
NPN catalog so the way that it works
they start actually wagon embeds haskell
with the application to just do all the
data science processing and things like
that with algorithm or machine learning
so i know the good thing if you already
have IP routine know that things
cross-platform you can embed that in the
package for your application and
shipment so again the communication
between processing an operating system
happening through the IPC so just change
that to make it IPC aware and one of my
favorite the subtly having a finish is
Nyla's that for some reason well let's
put the beginning at least see we have
here I just didn't I said try to do this
a top today and they wireless didn't let
me and in some mail client but if you
can't see the screenshot here like the
resolution is not very well it doesn't
look like a web application it has the
chromium chromium off of the chrome of a
Mac and each support problems as well
things things like that so you can't
create negative desktop applications you
just pure HTML and well the order it
would be your application product you
can just submit as well to the electron
website and there's like plenty of
applications down with electron they
does things that you cannot imagine a
good example of that is how many times
somebody ask you can we support video
conferencing in our application you
can't in a web application so you can
just now use as well video conferencing
in the using the day native desktop
let's say that you want to support a
speech with now their ApS that both Mac
and Windows have for a speech you can do
that as well in fact if there is
something native that you want to
support you can write as well your own
native modules to electron to do that
and chip it to with your application
alright so let's look at we've done the
demo so let's look at how we how to get
started I mean for a lot of people you
already have an existing application
that you're thinking about any how do I
actually move this across to electron
right so so how do we do it well the
first step is of course you know the URL
that you actually pilot you have on on
the JavaScript file where you do the
create
Roza you can basically chuck in the URL
okay it's like a first step but there
are issues over here all right Christian
yeah the biggest issue of course is
security yeah so let's let's talk about
like the first for one by one
yeah the first one is of course it's
going so the first one of course is to
serve the content server content from
the server so you're all your HTML all
your JavaScript and CSS and everything
is actually in the server and all you're
doing is passing the URL of your index
of history yeah actually this this could
be useful but very dangerous what happen
is that if you remember the first slide
one of the first days like that might
have showed that in the main process you
pass a URL that usually is a file saying
the the main page like this color like
the equivalent WPF of the main view
right or the main window so instead of
that what you can do is pass the full
URL of your web page in there in the web
right that is like the first man
approach you can just do that on the
shelf and it would just take like a few
lines of code but but it has certain
problems first it can be like subject to
cross the scripting because when you do
that you are running not in a sandbox
remember that browser that process is
not in a sandbox you have the IPC
support so you can actually connect
water processing your application
so if somebody gets into your web site
and inject harmful JavaScript code you
are pretty much is crew yeah I will
actually talk about this a little bit
later on how do you guys how to protect
on things like that so it's very useful
in certain occasions like for example
one of the things that we use it is that
we have like a mobile web server that is
we call it like that and we want the
people just to use the same direction so
we use banjul to detect which is the
which one is the server and then serve
the page from that URL so because we
have to do in that way
but that is the first man poor man
approach the second step is saying
moving that for whatever you have in the
world and do it locally and this is when
things became fun right because what you
have to do is not just move the UI that
is going to be in the browser process
but you have to move as well the backend
if your backing is in OGS is the easiest
thing ever
because you just basically have an
odious application lock running locally
let's say that you made your application
in Express or in core you just like run
it locally and your browser is talking
locally through localhost so it's pretty
simple in that case just just make sure
that you are using as well HTTPS or some
weather encryption between those two
endpoints the problem that you would
face there is like database and things
like that I will talk later
and the third thing is that now that you
will you did that you can leverage the
desktop you can make your application
look more like a desktop application so
see this as a many step if you have to
sell this to your boss and this was the
way that I sell it to him but a way as a
CTO I did that and say like in just one
hour okay look this is the application
running in the desk because they are the
first thing that I did was that it's
like oh yeah yeah how is working or just
this if you give me like another day I
will make it completely running locally
and I did the second step and now that
he was happy he gave me like more time
to make it look like a desktop
application but that's the way it is you
can see this as a as a step by step if
you have to migrate existing
applications to the desk to get to bring
the desktop experience and if it's you
know sometimes you may have things like
maybe API and so on it just gets a
little bit more complex
but this is where when you're starting a
brand new project I think you've got a
little bit more flexibility in your
options I suppose so
let's talk about that the first thing of
course is you've got it when you're
creating a new brand new application you
got to think of it more like a single
page application traditionally you know
when we used to write a lot of
applications we have lots and lots of
pages if you go click
on a certain Lincoln takes you there's
another link and then you hit the back
button and you go go back and things
like that remember that a lot of these
things don't exist anymore
right I like like there's no back button
on the electron shell lynnie exactly you
can provide your own back button but
what will you do that yeah that's right
so and and again you know got this thing
where room button design for the desktop
is one of those things right we do a lot
of design you know we all think of a
responsive design so now you know it's
got to work we built a an application
and it's all built in HTML and CSS I
want to run it on a mobile and suddenly
the responsive design it just fits into
a mobile device but you don't have to
deal with that anymore yeah see remember
we are not building a mobile application
over here we are actually designing the
to run on a disk now you can't just go
crazy with pixels if you want you want
20 pixel you've got 20 pixels like
because there's no other problem you
know the constraints that you
application is going to run yeah and
because it's a window application you
said like you know what this is the Mac
size this is the minimum size of the
renderer so don't you are not
constrained to those things the close
bottom is a good example Mahesh like for
example when you when you are displaying
you have an inventory of over a list of
people you want to see the details of
one and you're just clicking one person
and in a web application what you have
to do it's just displaying the same area
or use things like layover so things
like that to display the details and
provide a close button you don't have to
do this anymore if you want to because
it's a desktop application what you can
do is just expand another browser window
and not even provide a close button
because users already know how to close
a window they just click in the corner
right or in the corner is in Windows is
the other side right yeah so is that
it's just just look at a desktop
application and don't try to emulate a
desktop application anymore like we're
doing we're just use the desktop
facilities remember that there are many
options at their disposal and things
like that and say yeah you know you can
you can activate the menu
do things with it you can start thinking
about you know if you're putting it on a
system Tori how are you gonna use it how
are you going to be using the
notifications so you've got to start
thinking about like a desktop
application and move away from a little
bit of that web development mentality I
think yeah that's because of the
restrictions that I had now you don't
need like the typical boots all of you
how many of you have seen the bootstrap
templates everybody just use it right so
now you don't need the typical boot
strata in play with main area of a bang
area maze and yes you typically have
like a main navigation and then like a
secondary navigation and you'll have
like I don't know like a hero image or
something like that and followed by
content you don't have to stick to that
interestingly enough when you look at a
lot of the applications that are being
written in an electronic applications
like slack they all follow a certain
team missile now you have like your
navigation on the on the left hand side
and you have like a secondary navigation
that pops up after that and then you
have a content panel and things like
that you don't have to stick to it
obviously if you look at the 9 this
application it's very different it's a
mail client but so Kristi and so what do
we have to actually get people started
with templates itself right there are a
couple of templates that you can
actually use oh yeah if you really want
to just start with something already
made I seriously recommend photo it's
made by the guys from github as well one
of the designers that create like
already templates in CSS that are
basically like the math test oh that's
the only problem that because Maggie
school he just wanted to be mad guy
right but if you want to create real
cross-platform experiences this another
problem a react desktop that has no
relationship will react it's actually
done in that way that the same controls
has a windows look and feel and a Mac
look and feel so in that way you can
reuse the same controls but again
remember to the same for the desktop
yeah provide desktop experiences
somebody asked you before like somebody
asked me what about electron for mobile
devices I don't think that there are
technical reasons because that
never happen but electron is designed
for cover one problem and it's desktop
applications so I stopped thinking about
mobile and responsive design and things
like that and think about desktop let's
talk about build pipeline right oh it's
my favorite subject yeah I mean like
first thing is that as soon as you get
started the first thing that you should
work on is your build pipeline if you
don't I mean you should so let's talk
about builds pipeline Christine yeah
yeah we learn a lot around this bill
pipeline the first thing that you need
to understand together when design at
your application is which platforms you
are going to reach and use your build
agent in that platform yes you can build
Windows applications in Mac interesting
because you can now build Mike
applications in Windows right out so far
right at least for a lecture but even
when that happen just use up a build
agent in a Mac for Mac applications and
a Windows agent in Windows to build
Windows application well I mean agents
because I don't know if you are using
TFS or your recent team CD or whatever
it is but use the platform that you need
because the binaries that you will need
to provide and we will talk later the
packaging format that you are going to
distribute your application we use cloud
services in our case so we use tray DCI
for mac and we use a be your for Windows
another characteristic what I say there
is the packaging as I said do you need
to take care of the packaging because
the electron dot that you use is okay
but you don't expect your users to do
that so electron packages what it does
is that it prepares your application
ready to chip and generate an MSI
package for Windows application the
first install on a dmg package or a dmg
file for Mac applications and those you
can customize that you are seeing that
in dmg files when you double-click it
has like a nice background icon and
messages and things like that you can
customize that for your math application
the same for Windows so electron
packages take care of that for electron
package is one of the interesting things
that you have to take care is that if
you remember the package so Jason you
always have a death dependencies and
dependencies so just be careful with
that because electron packages is going
to include just the dependencies so they
be careful that the things that you need
for the well development are just in
depth the dependencies are so on for
example mocha for testing needs to be in
that dependency so in that way you don't
distribute that together with your
executive another thing that you I
learned this in the bad way is that you
go crazy with with modules right you go
like NPM and things like that and we
have to process we have the server
process running in Cora that was the API
system the communicates with the
database and things like that and the UI
that was written in react to communicate
with that to through rest protocols the
problem that we faced was that for local
processing West are using native modules
to communicate to things like for
example couch TV and frequent sequel
server at the beginning and we start
moving to electron we have certain
problems because even when the main
process that is who is path the Express
application in that case is basing note
is not note when you try to build it
will tell you I cannot recognize this
version of node because it's no call
note it's called electron so when you
use binary model modules aka databases
embedded system USB devices for example
that are available in an NPM repository
what electron rebuild does is that it
downloads the source code and repealed
the source code so it's compatible with
electron so you can use all those binary
modules that you seeing MTM but to make
it work with electron you have to
rebuild it but electron rebuild take
care of all the master
for doing that step another thing is
that with the electron you can reach us
where mass applications mass
applications are the Apple Store
application so you can just make an
electron application that is available
to distribute with Apple Store
guidelines there's just a checklist in
the electron website that is pretty
clear what you have to do to reach that
and of course being a developer the
couple of things they'd be interested in
one is what's the debugging experience
and how do you go about testing so if I
look at the debugging itself I mean
pretty much when you start electron from
the command line you can check in like a
command-line switch over there you
basically say - - debug and you specify
the port number that it actually runs in
and you'd be able to connect it from
Visual Studio code and and debug the
application in fact if you look at if I
jump into Visual Studio code now I can
actually start the I can debug this
application right out of Visual Studio
code so notice this debug thing that
they have over there a debug icon button
whatever you want to call it then you've
got two options over here one is the
launch and attach they're nothing more
than configurations in the launch JSON
file so I've actually gone ahead and
changed the runtime executable to point
to electron rather than node because
typically it actually launches the node
application and once I actually set this
up change the details and my
configurations I can affect Li go over
to my debug and then launch my
application right out of here I'd also
be able to set I'd be able to set
breakpoints in my code as well so if I I
think I've already got a breakpoint if I
quit this application notice that it's
actually
hit the breakpoint it stopped over here
so you can have a debug experience right
out of Visual Studio code if you want to
do now it's one thing I want to point
out now you can actually debug the main
process from Visual Studio code however
if you wanted to debug whatever's in
your render render process then you have
problem you can't do that so for that
you can actually do it right out of out
of chromium so let me show that as well
so I find that control shift I and I can
go over to my this let me open this
other one that's here let's say I put in
a breakpoint over here and if I do a
reload notice that it's actually hit the
debug
it's hit the breakpoint over here and
you can actually inspect your variables
and do all kinds of stuff so it's
actually it works out pretty pretty well
there's another tool named a deaf
electron that can do that as well and
you can see the IPC messages between
things like for example like that the
IPC message is going from the main
process to the browser if you want to
debug that communication so the
electronics as well I know that tool is
an open source tool that is available
okay testing this is interesting as well
because testing somebody asked yesterday
to me hey do we have well it was not to
me was I just like jumping I do that
sometimes
is there any webdriver
for selenium to run in electro and the
answer is kind of right because you can
just develop something like that but
remember that it's not just the renderer
process you have as well to see the
integration with the desktop
it's amazing that you have to test
things like for example when I click
when I click Edit copy actually copy the
information here in the clipboard it's
more than that it's just the whole
integration with the desktop
so there's that unum and spectrum that
is very much like selenium but for
desktop applications using electron so
you can test things in the same way that
you just do with selenium or you know
what if I click this thing this will
change in the menu and this will this
notification will pop up or they the
file dialogue the dialogue for file open
will appear that to come work in
headless installations that means no
installations that don't have a head is
that doesn't have an screen I so just be
careful with that because for linux
applications you have to install and a
specific x3 driver to just use the frame
buffer system to test in headlights
application that doesn't happen in
Windows or Mac but it's the only thing
for if you are you want to reach the
Linux desktop my advice is don't try to
reach all the three desktops at the same
time it's like a mobile application that
just see what is your customer first and
Windows and Mac you will be most common
and then if somebody ask just call
Wiggly nose but it's it's easy to test
with the spectrum in all these three
platforms and I think security is
probably oh yeah securities securities
you know especially after like every
every time that Troy hunt give a talk
and things like that and everybody gets
a scare yeah I think the first question
is it is it is it safe to run I mean I
know the first thing that we actually
did was say hey you know you can
actually throw in the URL of you know of
a location and you're you know when you
create the browser window and then you
run it but we also say that it's it's
okay when you're just doing a quick
prototype and it's it's it's a first
step in getting started but think about
it right so what if someone if you go in
and run you know untrusted remote
content and that starts injecting some
node scripts and you know you start
deleting files from your file system and
things you can actually do that now yeah
and that could happen bring them
you have access to everything so
somebody actually could do other scripts
and delete start from with see windows
and the only thing that is going to stop
you its permissions yeah so when you are
running remote content there's a way to
prune this what you do is you run it in
there and it within a webview tag and
that runs it within you know a sandbox
environment and then you also disabled
your node integration because you don't
want bad things happening in case you
know someone is able to inject it and
here's the key thing right even if you
trust the content let's say you're
serving pages from your own website or
whatever it is you got to be serving it
on HTTP so that you know that there's no
man in the middle attack and it's
injecting some random stuff and things
like that right so you've got to make
sure that you always run on HTTPS now if
you go to the if you go over to the
electron documentation they've got a
checklist of all the things that you
need to do and it's a pretty good I've
got one one good thing about electron is
that the documentation is actually
pretty good so there's a little
checklist of things I highly recommend
actually visiting that and having a look
at it yeah the other is at least I put
that in securities everybody can see my
quote when I say that you make your
application native it doesn't mean that
magically is compiled into binary code
you are distributing JavaScript files
right and I see many people telling me
hey how can I just office can my
JavaScript code the first thing that I
said you don't need to office code
JavaScript it's already--as it's office
gated right that is the feature in Java
screen but now like seriously what
happened with that code can I just
somehow distribute something that is no
JavaScript well the first answer is
using us our files as our files are the
cure equivalent to tables basically is a
compressed format with all your
JavaScript files it's part of the common
line so what instead of having like the
ten thousand files that you know is 4444
thousand if you're raising angular 2
files I'm putting in the in the file
system you just like compress everything
in a nasa file that has everything
inside so it's a mini file system to say
something like that the problem with a
surface is that they are anti temper
instant is not is it people can
decompress that and just inject more
things so it's just that very small
layer support of protection now if you
really really really want to protect
your IP and it's written in JavaScript
the next step you can probably try a
snapshots it snapshots are like kind of
difficult to use and the idea is simple
you know the v8 the JavaScript engine
from chrome what it does is that it
takes the JavaScript code and it has a
JIT system you just compile in time to
native so that compilation in time when
does that it generates native code and
put that native code in an area of
memory so there's a to name and n WT s
that you can just run it and it takes
that image that binary image and
generate a binary file with that
compilation so basically they hold your
JavaScript code or the compiled
JavaScript code will look in the memory
of chromium sorry of v8 in that moment
so that is another of the option using
it snapshots the problem with the
snapshots history snapshots are
read-only and certain things like for
example dynamic variables and things
like that are not possible to represent
because it would represent another it's
natural in time they tend to be really
big as well and my advice is if you
really want to protect your IP there are
two options here one is use native code
so writing the internet writing in
something like go so we're being
cross-platform so I will work good
example is lesson see John there link
back want to use just the UI using
electron
he already have the engine that does all
the autocomplete and things like that in
the backend that process could be an
exit file running in dotnet of course
ELR or whatever when if it's released
one day and then they rip the UI is just
electronic and they communicate between
then through IPC the guys from JetBrains
are doing something like that would
write it but it's just having three
chopper running and a separate engine
and the UI is done in IntelliJ and they
communicate through a very lightweight
protocol and try to leverage the cloud
so you can just like put all that
compilation and things like that in your
cloud system and they just communicate
the only disadvantage there is that is
very difficult to make it offline but
just just try to see see how valuable is
your IP I say this because there was a
casing in Cambodia the Cambodia went
through elections and the system that
they use was written in electron because
it was very delicate it's an election
data to avoid tampering what they end up
doing was writing that processing go to
make a like real cross-platform so think
about leveraging things like that
because you can actually finish up with
some tips and tricks Christina yeah as I
said the first bigotry is try don't try
to rewrite everything in JavaScript if
you already have something try just to
pack that together with your application
in our case for example we use many
things we try to replicate let's go
replicate the infrastructure that we
have in the cloud in a small set of
process running locally so in the cloud
we have a queue we use like the queue
system from the cloud so instead of that
we use like an a small queue system
running in the machine right no not just
msq or things like that just Ana small
cube process the same with database and
things like that so just leverage all
those parts I don't try to ship
everything together in the same
executable as possible just have it
small pieces that are distributed
together
don't try to remember
in JavaScript if you have to do a lot of
calculation and a lot of work use web
workers and what I mean again you have
chromium so what you can do is just
create web workers to do that
communication they communicate through
IPC as well and let them do like the
communication in in the background
remember that you are writing in note
and in JavaScript in there in the render
process and that means that it's just
single threaded include the DB with the
app this is my favorite part because we
are used to when he's in the cloud use
sequel server for example assure and
that has all the database but if we want
our application to be completely offline
that was our case we have to create a
way to have like a local database that
works well synchronized with the main
database the local database part was
easy we use sequel Lite for the we have
two types of database one is no SQL
database and and the other is the
relational database so our database
changing is independent off of the data
bury our data over M is in that array of
independent of the database so we have
sequel I running for the local instance
with their own schema and things like
that and in run since equalizer for the
cloud and for the no SQL database we use
in the cloud and with another one
that is lumen DB that is an embedded
database as well for no SQL that is
comparable with the protocol so you just
try to embed adding again a small
versions of those things running locally
an outer update is possible I didn't
show that but if you use just having
yeah if you just show Adam you will see
a small squirrel in the corner then
sometimes it's blue that means there is
an update one of the things that they
guys from the hub developed together
with Adam was a squirrel that is a cross
product from updating system
that what happen is that just use nougat
as a delivering mechanism or every time
that you have an update you just put a
new package
we'll out to update the application so
you can embed out to a debian your
application for free without any adding
anything so that is one of the problems
that is already soft and they already
have that honest cross-platform yeah I
mean this is critical right because when
you're deploying of every application
it's very easy you go deploy it on the
server one time and then everybody gets
it at the same time but when you got a
desktop application people have the code
running on their machine so you need to
be able to provide updates periodically
as well and you don't you can't expect
you know for them to actually go and do
it themselves but scrool you can
actually do a lot of water update you
can do the auto bit you can trigger that
off so that's all we actually had I mean
our aim was basically to do give you a
bit of an introduction to a electron and
get show you what kind of applications
are being written and just enough to get
you interested and get started
programming in yeah just go and try it
again like this salted the problem when
your boss as I said before say like
Christian we have to migrate this to the
desktop I just try it just use the
three-step and do it and he worked he's
just actually he's here so said thanks
for coming
those are tutor handles over there if
you need to if you got any questions you
can actually send this or we've still
got a couple more minutes I assume if
you got any questions alright at lumen
TV they just recently yes so what what
the question was what's the name of the
local no sequel database I will tell you
in a second yeah same I'm like list of
forks any other questions yes
okay so the question was what's your you
know opinion on using spa frame looks
like react and angular we've decided to
go react I mean we did a we went through
an exercise of trying to figure out
which one is better and needy be neat DB
and 8db yeah so so we ended up choosing
react I mean I'm not here to kind of
like debate whether angular is better or
reactors better yeah absolutely yep yep
yep yep so to the answer question we use
react so the answer is yes yeah no no it
was quite good actually yeah yeah it was
actually because what we did is we just
replaced the communication to two half
in the same process and then use IPC in
the local version so we didn't have like
any issue the only issue that we are not
issue but they expect that we are right
now is making it look more desktop light
and actually react has helped us a lot
with that because we just replace the
components for doing that the only thing
is that now we have to not force but we
have to two versions of the source code
and we are still learning because the
same as react is a new thing learning
how to make really big applications and
now we are till tackling two types of
applications and SPF for the web and a
desktop application so that's the only
problem we have aware of with having two
different versions of the source code
yeah one last question sorry
yeah you can you can you can they are
actually modules if you want to do that
we actually studying that because we
have a problem to solve in that way you
can create a module and NPM module that
is a window service then with the
desktop there's the other part the
person what you have to do I'm crazy as
hell so I wanted to do my own components
to just extend for example the Internet
Explorer browser
I almost there I already being able to
do that in Mac you know you think on
producing like the native desktop so you
can just do certain things in the Finder
window that are like just native but
it's possible yeah so you just you will
have to deal with if you want to do that
integration are you like go up spread
step further expect to just get your
hands dirty
yeah we're out of time guys but we'll
take questions like yeah I will be
around
so this or is no mean yet and and make
sure you pick the put the green notes on
the way out now